It is true. It is true that when it
comes to Gentiles, you can enslave them
and you are not obligated to set them
free. But why is that cruel? Why is is
that like cruel?
Why different rules for slave uh
Gentiles? Now again, you're going to see
the wisdom of God. Now, I know people
are not going to like this, right?
I know people are not going to like
this. They're going to say, "Ah, come
on, man. you know,
you're just trying to justify the Bible.
Okay, before I go to Leviticus 25 and
Deuteronomy 20, you don't need to go
there, but let me just explain this.
What is the wisdom in God
saying that a Hebrew Israelite cannot
remain in perpetual servitude? Seventh
year or the Jubilee year, all debts,
slaves are set free, especially if it's
a female servant. But with Gentiles on
the other hand, Gentiles on the other
hand, if you enslave them, you're not
required to set them free. For example,
if you go to Leviticus, read chapter 25
to 46. I'm going explain to you the
justice. Okay, understand? Now, I'm
going to show you if you have eyes to
see, what seems to be evil actually
becomes a blessing. Are you guys
enjoying this discussion or am I boring
you? You guys okay? You're learning,
trying my best to speak clearly by the
grace of God's spirit. Leviticus 25:45
to 46
>> 45 You may also buy some of the
temporary residents living among you and
members of their clans born in your
country and they will become your
property. You can
be
>> them meaning you can pass them as an
inheritance
>> to your children as inherited property
and can make them slaves for life. But
you must not rule over your fellow
Israelites ruthlessly.
>> Wow. Why Israelites? You cannot enslave
them for life but Gentiles. Now you guys
want to see God's wisdom if you read
deeper and not just read with hatred and
hostility.
>> You want me to now go deep? All right.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
The nations surrounding Israel were
steeped in infanicide, b m murdering
children, beastiality, having sex with
animals, homosexuality,
lesbianism,
incest, murder, and idolatry. By
enslaving them, you become a moral
deterrent where you stop them from
committing those evils. So number one,
this is punishment for their sin.
Because you're a cancer that needs to be
checked because we don't check you,
you're going to spread this poison and
corrupt the land. So in enslaving them,
you're stopping them from committing
that evil because once they're your
slaves, they can't do those things in
the land of Israel. It's number one. So
it's punishment and a moral deterrent.
Stop them. But now, let me show you
God's wisdom and beauty. If that gentile
then repents of their gods and goddesses
and now is convinced the God of Israel
is the true God, guess what happens?
Guess what happens?
>> He goes free. He goes free.
>> Go to Leviticus.
Well, here just read Leviticus 25. Read
47 to the end.
First with that. Leviticus 25. Read 47
to the end. Now, watch the wisdom of
God. Watch here. If you want to read and
say, "God, I'm having a hard time
understanding these commands, but I know
you're a just God. You're a good God,
and you're not evil, and your commands
are good. Can you show me?" And he will.
So now read.
>> If a foreigner residing among you become
rich and any of your fellow Israelites
become poor and sell themselves to the
foreigner or to a member of the
foreigner's clan, they retain the right
of redemption after they have sold
themselves. So a foreigner who lives
like you in the land and is an
Israelite, he too must let go, let a
Hebrew Israelite free like you.
So if I'm an Israelite and I own an
Israelite as a butler or a maidervant,
but there's an Egyptian who's living in
the land because he worships a God of
Israel, he cannot permanently enslave a
Hebrewite. He has to let him go as well.
You understand the point?
>> Yes.
>> Keep going.
>> One of their relatives may redeem them.
An uncle or a cousin or any blood
relative in their clan may redeem them.
Or if they prosper, they may redeem
themselves. They and their buyers,
>> slave, a Hebrew slave can set himself
free.
>> Yes,
>> he makes enough money by serving his
master, he can set himself free. But
keep going.
>> They and their buyers are to count the
time from the year they sold themselves
up to the year of the jubilee. The price
for their release is to be based on the
rate paid to hire to a hired worker for
that number of years.
>> Did you catch it? He's being treated as
a worker, a butler.
>> Yes.
>> What I said, a hired worker, an
employee, like a butler, not a slave
like the way Muslims enslaved people or
what they do in Keep going.
>> If many years remain, they must pay for
their redemption. A large share of the
peace paid for them. If only a few years
remain until the year of Jubilee, they
are to compute that and pay for their
redemption accordingly. They are to be
treated as worker hired from the year to
year. You must see to it that those to
whom they owe service do not rule over
them ruthlessly
>> all the way.
>> Even if someone is not redeemed in any
of these ways, they and their children
are to be released in the year of
Jubilee.
>> That's the 50th year. Every 50th year is
the year of Jubilee. They go free.
>> For the Israelites belong to me as
servants. They are my servants whom I
bought out of Egypt. I am the Lord your
God.
>> So no one can own the Israelites.
They're my servants. I own them. You can
hire them as butlers and maidervants,
but you cannot own them permanently.
They're my permanent possession. See
what he's saying?
>> Yes, sir. So that tells you not every
form of slavery is evil because to be a
slave of God is good and righteous. But
how does this tie in with the foreigner?
Now remember the rule here. Well, how
does this apply to the foreigner? Now go
to Leviticus 19 33-34. I hope you guys
are learning that if you try to
understand these commands in its
context, historical cultural context,
you'll see God's wisdom. You'll see it
right. Leviticus 19:33-34.
When a foreigner resides among you in
your land, do not mistreat them. The
foreigner residing among you must be
treated as your native born, love them
as yourself. For you were foreigners in
Egypt, I am your Lord.
>> Okay, I'm confused. So if a
non-Israelite
has now come to live in our land and he
now repents of the gods and goddesses
and he now worships the God of Israel
and follows the same covenant. Treat him
as an Israelite, not a foreigner.
>> Correct?
>> So what if I enslave someone from the
nations who's a pagan, but he now
repents and he worships the God of
Israel and now follows the covenant. How
am I supposed to treat him?
>> As your brother native born. In other
words, I can't then keep him permanently
a slave, right?
>> No, he's a maximum of five years.
>> Well, I mean, not five years at seventh
year is I know the Sabbath rest. Don't
quote me on this because I know in the
50th year, you'll release everyone and
dents are canceled. But you get it. If
he's now
worshiping the God of Israel, following
the covenant, and doing everything that
God told Israelites to do, what does God
say? How are you supposed to view him?
as your native born.
>> But didn't God say that if you have a
Hebrew who's your servant, you cannot
permanently make him your servant? You
have to let him the right to redeem
himself or be redeemed and you let him
go in the 50th year.
>> Yes, sir.
>> So if a foreigner now is worshiping the
God of Israel and you are to treat him
like if he himself is an Israelite,
isn't that same rule applicable to him?
>> Absolutely.
>> So then who are the Gentiles that you
can permanently own? those who don't
repent, those who want to still worship
their gods.
But what if they worship the God of
Israel? Then now he's one of you. Treat
him like you. He's not a foreigner
anymore. He is an Israelite in my sight.
In other words, the Bible even teaches
the concept of being a spiritual
Israelite.
>> Awesome. Awesome.
>> Now go to Deuteronomy 10:18 to19.
>> All right.
Did it take it to everyone? Did everyone
get it or no?
>> I don't know if you guys are bored with
this. These guys are like they're bored.
Am I boring you guys? Honestly, let me
know.
>> They Okay, so you asked them. I'm not
bored. By the way, brother, I have
another question. So, I'm putting you on
a hot seat again and again today because
this your answers helps me a lot.
>> So, I'm going to put you in another help
uh hot seat.
>> So, the question would be,
isn't that force conversion?
No, you can still remain a pagan, but
your punishment is you need to be
enslaved because you're dangerous
because of your paganism, which leads to
corruption of the land and spreading
immorality. No, you can remain a pagan.
It's up to you. But that's your
punishment because your gods didn't
create you. Our God did. He owns you.
And this is your punishment,
right? Mhm.
>> The punishment is also for his benefit
and that you're constraining him from
corrupting others,
polluting others as well as himself. For
example, when you constrain a gentile
who's commanded to offer children as a
sacrifice, when you enslave him, you
save children that he could have end up
murdering.
>> Correct. Correct. Absolutely. So you see
it's saving others from his filth and
immorality and also saving himself
because for example let's say he's free
and he's homosexual or he's he's someone
who sleeps with animals. We know this
medically. This is a fact. This is a
medical fact. People who engage in
homosexual relations have shorter
lifespan because when you have that kind
of sex you do irreparable damage to the
rectum. I'm trying to be keep it G-rated
so I don't get too technical because
that part of the body is not meant to be
penetrated. It's meant to for poop. So,
not only do you damage a person's rectum
where now that person can't control his
bowel movements, that's why a lot of
homosexuals when they get older, they
wear diapers. I don't know if you know
this but you also get the partner who's
penetrating you also you pass on disease
because when that person penetrates that
area which is where all the fecal matter
come out you are now passing on disease
to that person that's why they get AIDS
and HIV
>> well that's already a very disgusting
thing it's coming out of that thing yeah
I'm I'm saying it's just disgusting I
don't know who does that it's disgusting
It's poop there, you know. You don't
touch your poop, you know.
>> But that's how do you think they get
intimacy?
>> These are serious issues to talk about.
>> Correct.
>> In fact, in the 80s, you'll find videos
on YouTube confirming this. HIV was
called the gay cancer. Did you know
that?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Why? Because they realized that this is
only spread among the homosexual
community.
Then how did it then spread to
heterosexuals? Because who are bisexual
would sleep with men and women. Then
they passed on AIDS to the woman who
then passed it on to their partners.
Had they not done that, it was just
homosexuals. It would never spread to
the heterosexual community. Do you know
that?
>> No. But now I do.
>> Yeah. That's why this is I'm not making
it up. So what's my point? When you take
a pagan who steeped in incest and this
is Leviticus 18 and Leviticus 20, God is
saying this is what the Egyptians is
what the Canaanites are doing. This is
why I'm destroying them and removed from
the land. He gives you a list. Father
sleeping with daughter, mother sleeping
with son, man sleeping with man, man
sleeping with animal and not only that
but sleeping
having orgies because did you know part
of pagan practice they have orgies? Did
you know that?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> It's even in Hinduism, right? When you
go and you have orgies as an act of
worship to the gods and goddesses.
So, and then taking children and
offering them as sacrifices. So when you
enslave these people, you stop that
filth, you stop that poison, you stop
that corruption, and you constrain them,
saving other people like children from
being murdered and saving themselves
from doing reparable damage to their own
bodies.
Now, however, once they turn to God and
fear God and follow his commands, you
are no longer to treat them as a
gentile. They're now a fellow Israelite.
Deuteronomy 10:18-19
>> 18-19
He defends the cause of the fatherless
and the widow and loves the foreigner
residing among you giving them food and
clothing and you are to love those who
are foreigners for you yourself were
foreigners in Egypt. So, how fair is the
God of the Bible? You went to 20. Stop.
How fair is the God of the Bible saying
to Israelites, "Look, I love the
foreigners.
I love the strangers. I love those who
are not ethnically Israelites just like
I love you and I love the fathers and
the widow. I love them all equally.
Therefore, you better love them and
treat them as one of your own."
See it?
>> Mhm. And then on top of that, God even
said a time will come when he restores
the land that even Gentiles who are not
ethnically Jews will have a portion of
the land allotted to them. Ezekiel
47:22-23.
>> Uh if you want to show the screen, you
can. You are to allot it as an
inheritance for yourself and for the
foreigners residing among you and who
have children. You are to consider them
as nativeborn Israelites. So
non-Israelites who are ethnically not
Jews or Israelites, consider them as
Israelites as if they were born from
Israelite parents, they're one with you.
>> Absolutely.
>> Keep going.
>> Along with you, they are to be allotted
an inheritance among the tribes of the
Israel. In whatever tribe a foreigner
resides, there you are to give them
their inheritance, declare the sovereign
Lord.
>> How fair could God be? Could he be any
more fair? Did you guys catch it?
Leviticus 19:33-34, Deuteronomy
10:18-19. And here, Ezekiel 47:22,23, he
says to Israelites, "When a foreigner
loves me and worships me and turns to me
and wants to follow the covenant, he is
equal to you. He's just as much an
Israelite in my sight as he is as you
are. You are to treat him as if he was
born from Israelite parents and do not
discriminate." So the same law of
servitude applies to them. That means I
cannot permanently enslave a foreigner,
right? Because he says the same law.
So that means there's hope for a gentile
that I've taken captive and made a
slave. If he turns and worships the God
of Israel, I can't hold him as a captive
permanently anymore because now he's an
Israelite. So here already in the Old
Testament you have the New Testament
teaching that there are people who are
spiritual Jews
in the eyes of God.
>> Interesting. Interesting. Interesting.
So that that guy actually becomes land
inheritor.
>> Yeah. Right here.
>> Like that's that's crazy. Like he
becomes a land inheritor. He's like a
Jew now at spiritually.
>> And this is Old Testament. So the New
Testament is simply confirming what the
Old Testament taught. There'll be
Gentiles who will become spiritual
Israelites, Jews in the sight sight of
God.
And they may be even more blessed than a
native Jew. Because if a native Jew does
something abominable, he'll be cut off.
But that foreigner will remain.
>> Nice.
>> Yes, I like. So you saw it, Kitty. Was I
clear? Glory to the father, son, and
spirit. All glory to the father, son,
and holy spirit. If I spoke clearly, all
glory to the spirit for anointing me to
speak clearly. If I make mistakes, may
correct me on the spot, save me from
error.
Okay, you see that, right? So, it's
punishment for their sin
>> and it's a deterrent to stop them from
spreading corruption and a way of
convicting them to repent because if
they turn to the God of Israel, then
they'll be treated as Israelite and they
won't be permanent slaves anymore. See,
this is the wisdom of God.
I like what Mr. said, my brother. I love
this guy.
>> Perfect.
>> Now, has that helped you brother?
>> It does. It does. You have no idea how
much it it helped me and it will going
to help so many other people who listens
to